this man
is about to dive 20 meters off the top
of a cruise ship
what will happen to his body when he
hits the water
well luckily for him and others
the impact of hitting the water wouldn't
be the worst part
of going overboard the worst part
would be what would come next being
lost at sea even if you're wearing a
life jacket
surviving all alone in a giant body of
water until
someone rescues you will not be easy
what would be the biggest threat to your
survival
how could fish eyes save your life
and how long would you have before the
water
starts breaking down your skin
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you spent 24 hours lost at sea
[Music]
we say 24 hours because it's a nice
familiar number but the reality is that
you'll be lucky
if you even last that long hypothermia
can set in within minutes
and dehydration and exhaustion would
soon follow
one crucial thing to keep in mind is
that
you'd be surrounded by salt water you
can't drink it but it could save you
from drowning
[Music]
it's a lot easier to drown in fresh
water than it is to drown in salt water
about 90 of all drownings occur in fresh
water
not only is salt water more buoyant than
fresh water but
it's also safer to inhale
if you're going to drown in salt water
it's because the water you inhaled into
your lungs
stopped you from getting oxygen and
expelling carbon dioxide
but with fresh water it can be a little
more complicated
fresh water can kill you even after it's
been removed from your lungs
when you inhale salt water the higher
salt concentration
prevents the water from crossing into
your lung tissue
when you inhale fresh water it can enter
unprotected lung cells and
make them swell until they burst
this can lead to such severe damage that
you might not recover
even after the water is removed from
your lungs
but salt water has its drawbacks too
if you only have salt water around you
dehydration can be a major threat
if the hot sun is beating down on you
dehydration can begin
in about an hour you'll be losing water
from sweating
urinating and even breathing
as dehydration sets in you'll start to
feel extremely
thirsty dizzy confused and fatigued
none of that will raise your chances of
survival
if you're lucky it will rain rainfall
will provide a good source of drinkable
water
just lay on your back and open your
mouth
but if you don't get any rain you'll
need to be
a little more creative try to catch a
large
fish if you're successful then all you
have to do is eat its eyes
[Music]
big fish eyes are full of watery liquid
that will
surely quench your thirst yeah i know
it's gross but
there's no time to think about that
because you still have to worry about
hypothermia
[Music]
generally you can expect to survive in 5
degree water for
10 to 20 minutes before your muscles
will get weak
and you lose your strength and
coordination
this happens because the blood moves
away from the furthest parts of your
body
and towards the core the best way to
prevent hypothermia
is to pull your knees up to your chest
and keep them there
so that you can retain as much heat as
possible the less you move around
is also better for conserving your
energy
and not attracting predators as
you've probably gathered from the past
few minutes finding yourself in this
scenario
would be very bad your best bet at
surviving in the sea
is to avoid getting into this situation
in the first place
if you're going out on a fishing trip or
boat remember to tell people where
you're planning on going
and when you're supposed to be back
technology
is making it easier to find people who
get lost in water but
the more information the better when it
comes to rescue missions
you'd want to be rescued from the water
as soon as possible because
being submerged in water for any longer
than 24 hours
can lead to your skin breaking down if
this happens
you'll have open sores and you would
have a greater risk of
fungal and bacterial infections even if
the water is completely sterile
don't believe me well maybe you should
test it out by
sitting in a full bathtub for a few days
straight
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you